America's a country built by
hard-working folks people who aren't
afraid to go the extra mile to get the
job done so why would you expect
anything less from your turbo our
turbines are made right here in the US
of A built to last just like you we set
the industry standard 100 percent
preshrunk cotton your head could shrink
but these won't with two double stitch
reinforced pockets they're built for a
man on the go when it comes to comfort
no other mainstream turbine manufacturer
comes close
you might even forget you're wearing one
hey guys nice turbans government for one
more Wrangler real comfortable turbans
[Music]